heute kann es regnen stürmen oder
schneien
denn ich strahle ja selber wie ein
sonnenschein
heute ist mein geburtstag darin vorjahr
ich alle meine freunde interessieren
sich nicht für mich
alle meine freunde interessieren sich
nicht für mich wie schön das ich geboren
wurde
sonst hab dich so mich so sehr vermisst
wie schön dass ich hier alleine
ich gratuliere mir geburtstagskind den
bis heute habe ich geburtstag wie man an
dieser torte vielleicht schon erkennen
kann ich werde 24 jahre alt und ihr habt
wahrscheinlich schon meinen geburtstag
und weil ich hatte übersah gehabt darf
ich mir jetzt was wünschen
hallo leute ich es wieder einmal wanne
und willkommen zu einem neuen video im
geburtstags special version weil ich
heute geburtstag habe und ich habe
natürlich einen benjamin blümchen torte
dafür gekauft wie sollte das auch anders
sein
ich freue mich ich hatte so lange keine
benjamin blümchen torte
das war früher war das einfach der
schritt wenn du so eine benjamin
blümchen twitter hat ist wo mache ich
jetzt die kerzen hände ja also
geburtstag
ich möchte mit euch über geburtstage
reden das ist doch gut oder
das können wir machen das hat so lange
gebaut die kerzen darauf zu backen
ok ich schneide mir jetzt ein stück ab
ja gut durch dieses benjamin blümchen
ding kommt man bestimmt nicht ist
eigentlich traurig alleine kuchen zu
essen oder ich meine es kuchen ist
niemals traurig
ich werde wahrscheinlich eher das ganze
ding alleine auf essen
aber der wille zählt wir stellen das mal
hier viele tore ich liebe tod und dazu
habe ich mir einen kaffee geholt das ist
gut aber ich dachte mal dass wir heute
zusammen herausfinden was so geburtstags
bräuche über die ganze welt verteilt
sind und woher geburtstags bräuche so
kommen und ich möchte euch heute von
meinen lieblings geburtstags
erinnerungen erzählen und wenn die auch
heute geburtstag hat dann freut es mich
sehr happy birthday man diese benjamin
blümchen dort und mein gott ist die gut
lecker wie gab es auch früher die coolen
kids haben früher bei mcdonald's die
butter gefällt also nicht direkt bei
merck damit wenn man war dann immer erst
mal so schwimmen also das waren die
meisten geburtstage an die ich mich
erinnern kann war schwimmen und danach
ist man zu mcdonald's gegangen und dann
gab es neben dem blümchen torte und die
haben immer noch von mcdonald's sohn
geschenkt gekriegt hab auch immer diesen
raum
das gab es extra raum mit somit zum
thron habe ich jetzt gar nicht mehr so
gesehen
wir hatten auch bei uns in hamburg ich
komme aus hamburg bei uns in hamburg
hatten wir so einen ganz besonderen
mcdonald's mcdonalds play place oder
hieß es
in hamburg war der oder so ein sonar
hauptstraße da gab es auch so ein
spielparadies für kinder
es war einfach so standards mcdonald's
zu gehen und da sein geburtstag zu
feiern
ich würde mein kind niemals erlauben bei
ich werde nicht so eine bio mama glaube
ich irgendwann meine mama behindern
werde ich davon oder auch nicht das ding
ist meine schwester zum beispiel hat
schon kind und als ich damals schon
angefragt habe also wenn sie sachen
gemacht hat habe ich halt meinen senf
dazu beigetragen
wann das hat sie gehasst weil ich hab
kein kind ich weiß nicht wie das ist
wenn ich dann mit meinen sprüngen kommt
ich denke das ist besser wenn du das so
und so machst mit deiner tochter die
mich mal geguckt wer wird diesmal mama
dann weißt du wie das ist
deswegen sage ich jetzt wahrscheinlich
dass dessen mitmachen würde
und am ende sind sich mit meinem kind
bei mcdonald's ohne torhüter
ein komischer hast du immer eine tolle
leute genommen haben man hat mcdonald's
nicht eine eigene torte gemacht oder
haben immer die eltern das war von
mcdonald's keine ahnung warum mein gott
diese torte ist so lecker obwohl er
künstlicher er beigeschmack bei ist die
dass sie aber kugel ist er bei geschmack
gut auf einer künstlich ist ich bin aber
coppenrath und wiese hielt die torte ist
ja von coppenrath wiese
die machen schon echt gute torten also
dafür dass es dann immer so günstig ist
und so schon k s papier benjamin nicht
bei mir den kopf das ist so bescheuert
mit diesem kerzen weil wenn du sie
länger an hast dann tropfte das wachs
immer so runter auf den huchen zuwachs
zurück geburtstags bräuche auf der welt
woher kommen geburtstags broich was
macht man so an seinem geburtstag in
timbuktu netz find out brauche auf jeden
fall noch ein stück torte bevor das hier
so richtig losgeht
[Musik]
eine ganze benjamin blümchen torte für
mich alleine
ich warte erstmal einem laden in einem
supermarkt dessen name ich nicht nennen
möchte
hatten sie den ich dann musste ich
richtig weit laufen zum nächsten haben
sie zu holen
jetzt zum glück schon gestern gemacht
weil meistens wenn ich so fertig
gebohrten hole vergesse ich das wieder
gefroren sind und von inhalten und die
hat jetzt genug zeit um aufzuhören
geburtstags bräuche
haben euch eigentlich mal in der anderen
video schon gefallen habt ihr die
geschaut
ich hoffe ja ich habe mir sehr viel mühe
gegeben es ist sehr sehr stressig sieben
videos für sieben tage zu machen wenn du
eigentlich ein bis zwei videos macht ich
habe aber jetzt war auch gemerkt dass
ich viel mehr videos machen kann wenn
ich mich voll strukturiere weil meistens
ich habe mit youtube hat angefangen dann
habe ich halt immer wenn ich eine idee
hatte habe ich seit gedreht so und ich
habe mir nicht überlegt was mache ich in
zwei wochen für ein video sondern es war
so ich möchte das drehen also drehe ich
das jetzt und so hab ich das beibehalten
ich merke aber dass wenn ich auch mal
denke das möchte ich drehen das drehe
ich dann jetzt um ist dann in zwei
wochen hochzuladen um auch mal zwei
wochen da was zu haben und nicht immer
nur mittags zustehen ok was will ich
diese woche drehen
das ist sehr gut und ich habe sieben
videos geschafft hoffe ich also morgens
steht auch noch ein tag ist ja erst
video nummer sechs war mist monks zu
machen
ganz viele von euch haben auch gefragt
wenn ich mal wieder eins mache und wir
machen auch vor spaß weil ich mag es
einfach mit euch zu sprechen ohne mir
jetzt den text zu überlegen deswegen das
muss man halt so die perfekte
möglichkeit dafür
ich weiß viele mögen das nicht in den
kommentaren über sei oft aber ich kann
dir nicht beim essen nicht gar nicht
beim gucken
das tut mir leid und ist das einfach
auch kein format für dich es tut mir
leid dass die dann die informationen die
ich hier weiter gebe nicht weil die
ankommen aber ist das halt auch manchmal
so muss ja alles von mir wissen also da
muss man haben schon durch kaum durch
viele haben gesagt man zu machen
und sogar die bild hat einen artikel
über mit bangs geschrieben und ich war
erwähnt worden
das war ein sehr schöner moment in der
bild gewesen zu sein und ja auch
interviewanfragen gekriegt von leuten
die mit mir darüber sprechen wollen
und einer der eine studie darüber macht
warum leute anderen leuten beim essen zu
gucken ob das irgendwie so eine art
befriedigung ist oder so ich weiß nicht
ob das befriedigen ist jemand anderem
essen zogen
ich finds ja doch schon aber nicht auf
so überhaupt nicht so eine sexuelle also
ist hat mich voll an und wird sie auch
leute gibt
jetzt glaube ich wirklich gerne aber es
gibt halt ich glaube alles auf dieser
welt turnt irgendjemanden irgendwie auf
unser komische weise an also jeder hat
so seine fetisch glaube ich ja was ich
aber sagen möchte ist das deshalb
einfach weil sie nicht entspannt ist
besonders wenn du irgendwie sehr viel
stress hass und und keine ahnung denn
dem grab irgendwie nervig ist und du
denkst du ich will kurz mal fünf minuten
was anderes denken oder mich einmal kurz
berieseln lassen ich meine podcast wir
auch und das ist ja irgendwie so eine
art von podcast nur das sind spannend
irgendwie ist wenn jemand dabei ist also
ich finde ich will es okay also ich sags
ja es ist komisch darüber zu sprechen
oder aber auch als mr videos ich höre ja
wirklich gerne mehr videos auch zum
einschlafen weil ich das total mag wenn
wir jemandem ohr so rum raschelt oder
wenn er so kratz oder geräusche sind das
ergebnis aber es gibt halt wiederum
leute die das hat total ätzend finden
die das überhaupt nicht abkönnen was ich
auch stinkern weil ich meine jeder mag
nicht das gleiche und klar es ist sowas
was ist auch noch nicht so lange gibt es
gibt ja erst so durchs internet durch
youtube dieses im erzeugt
deswegen kennen das hat auch viele nicht
und deswegen was der bauer nicht kennt
frisst er nicht oder nicht und läuft mit
einer fackel dagegen
aber eigentlich ist die resonanz von
euch ist sehr gut also dafür dass ich
das ins internet stelle und auf youtube
jeder kommentieren kann waren die leute
noch sehr nett zu mir auch wenn ich ihn
vor der kamera was esse und jesus stück
nummer drei aber ich bin auch ein großer
moment wird so eigentlich für die kinder
eine torte wenn ich es schaffe die auf
zu essen dann kann ich das video nennen
eine ganze eine ganze benjamin blümchen
torte hatte sanel dafür mein gott wenn
jetzt können wäre dann würde ich meine
augen haben meine augen sind schon groß
genug
eine ganze reihe stehen dort aber so ein
video hochgeladen wo er nur die also wo
er ihr wisst was ich meine freunde sagen
wo er alles hochgeladen hat diese ganzen
some nail aufnahmen wenn du irgendwie
gemacht und ein schönes haben dann
wird's dann machst du halt meistens
irgendwie so und guckst du lustig in die
kamera damit du es dann halt später
rausschneiden kannst und halt als
amtmann benutzen kann und hat ein video
davon gemacht für den ganzen aufnahmen
es ist so lustig weil das halt einfach
sondern immer so ein stiller momente da
rede ich die ganze zeit gesagt leute
hallo wie geht's euch da hier sommerloch
allerdings sitzt du ein sehr schöner
moment sieht man wie dort ja ich habe
ein bisschen überlistet oder naja
ihr müsst ja auch denken dass meine haut
perfekt aussieht keine hier jetzt
realistisches nicht reinmachen gerade
gesehen dass ich hier bin ich hab sowie
süßigkeiten und es wird gegessen wenn
ich keine süßigkeiten essen habe ich
eine so schöne haut oh mein gott
wirklich die schönste haut der welt und
dann herzlich ein paar tage stade oder
so die kof instagram auch gezeigt ich
natürlich schokolade gegessen zu die
schokolade eigentlich als lecker ich
dachte man das passt nicht wegen scharf
und süß und so aber es passt richtig gut
fand ich richtig lecker betriebe wurden
schlechter auch nicht es gibt leute da
draußen die müssen mit viel mehr
probleme mit ihrer haut leben da geht es
mir noch recht gut ich habe mit zwölf
glaube ich pickel bekommen als einer der
ersten
und dann war auch ziemlich viel aber wir
waren schon mit 15 wieder weg andere
haben dann erst so richtig bekommen wir
ja noch was anderes machen die kriegen
einfach diesen pubertät pickel über
pickel sprechen und kuchenessen
pubertäts haut und andere ging ja
wirklich akne und da finde ich das auch
mal so gemeint dass man über diese leute
zu urteilt das meiste glück haben die
menschen mit dieser für sich haut die
auch immer so straff weshalb aber ich
hasse es wenn leute mit einer guten haut
dann über leute mit akten oder so so
ablästern als ob die das irgendwie
nachvollziehen können wie sich das
anfühlt wenn die haut hat nicht so gut
ist oder wenn man voll probleme halt
damit hat und dann kommen da immer so
sprüche wie ja ja die bildung so viel
make-up die die gespachtelt sich das
gesicht zu ja weil es ihr unangenehm
weil sie sich dann besser fühlt ich
finde das halt leider doch nicht über
dieses thema wenn du halt absolut keine
ahnung davon hast ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen ich finde wenn jemand mit akne
nicht so zugedeckt ist ich rede nicht
mehr mit der person und denke mir dann
ganz so ungefähr haut das ist dann für
mich also ganz normal
es ist tatsächlich so dass wenn sich
jemand sehr zu schmiert dass man dann er
anfängt so hinten gespräch so zu denken
die hat also ganz schön unreine haut
weil sie das so nun aber im endeffekt
ist es halt deren sache
wenn einer von euch da so ein typ von
ist da die männer auch leitner
also wenn er dürfen sie schminken aus
die glossy marvin müller cent ich liebe
euch alle
sogar ein bild mit marvin mit aussiedler
und mit namen habe ich auch ganz viele
letzte wort gesprochen also nicht in
letzter zeit sondern ist schon länger
her ist jetzt gar den elch guckt euch
mal fleißig seine videos meiner doch
nicht aber sag ich dir der regelfall
und besonders wenn du noch so 15 uhr in
der schule bist und dich dann springst
ist also dann die schüler sind gemein
und dann will ich lieber wegen meiner
schlechten haut gebucht werden als
vorwand benutzt michael h und da haben
halt mädchen glück wenn das bei uns mit
dem pickel anfängt und wo dann könnt ihr
unsere zukleistern was eigentlich die
pegel noch schlimmer macht muss man
sagen wenn ihr gerade durch die phase
geht und pickel bekommt durch das ganze
abdecken und links macht jetzt
eigentlich schlimmer am besten ist bio
seife benutzen teebaumöl nicht so viel
zucker essen zink salbe kamille kamin es
geht gut gegen entzündungen ihr könnt
kamillentee auf wattepads machen und das
euch so auf die haut machen weil die
gewinnentwicklung entzündungen und
kamille ist entzündungshemmend teebaumöl
des unternehmens hemd und ich haben ein
gebiet so viel gesprochen
es ist mein geburtstag ich möchte über
ich möchte über
schöne dinge sprechen ok geburtstags
bräuche die schönsten geburtstags
bräuche aus aller welt von der
sächsischen zeitung
aber nicht vor den flüchtlingen
okay das ist auch gemein nicht jeder aus
sachsen als nachdem sorry
einst galt der geburtstag einzig als
heidnischer brauch wir sind alles am
christentum ersatzweise der namenstag
zelebriert wurde
also die heiden haben geburtstag
gefeiert und bestimmt ja die christen
feiern namenstag bestimmt meine familie
in polen ist alle tief katholische
menschen ja auch katholisch aber ich sag
mal so eingedeutscht darling mann war
ich das letzte mal eine kirche zur
hochzeit und davor muss ich musste immer
wenn ich in polen war bei meiner familie
ich musste immer sonntags in die kirche
und chance aber auch ich fand es
wirklich schön also ich finde kirchen
sind toll und als kind ist es irgendwie
fand ich ja es hat so du hast so ein
wohlig warmes heiliges gefühl weil du
singst mit den leuten der priester
erzählt ihr dass liebe deinen nächsten
und so das ist halt nichts es hat halt
nicht sektenartige svi es fiel immer
darstellen also es ist halt ich finde
die kinder es ist schön so also und
eigentlich ist ja auch der sinn der
kirche auch irgendwie zu helfen also
früher nicht früher was die kirche alles
gemacht hat so eine macht die kirche
hatte und wie wir sind einfach scheiße
gebaut hat also menschen getötet für
irgendwelche scheiße und ich glaube
sogar die christen haben weil viel mehr
leute getötet
der islam und jetzt wird das immer so
dargestellt - so touristen sind sie
nicht weiß ich dass ich hasse dieses
thema geht wählen leute sorgt dafür dass
es aufhört irgendwann europa wird so
rechts gerade wo ich mir denke leute
immer haben wir jetzt hier gerade
wiederholungen von sachen die es schon
passiert sind
ich denke nicht ich glaube auch in polen
das ist ungerecht da habe ich mal mein
bruder gefragt wie der das so fühlt und
der meinte findet er scheiße aber man
spürte er hat erst mal gesagt nicht erst
noch nicht recht sondern habe ich so
dass nun doch geschäfte schulen rechte
knie und ich weiß jetzt gar nichts
geändert hat
irgendwie aber mein bruder haben sie uns
noch mal in schutz nehmen bruder das
nicht rächt meine mutter kommt um mein
gott leute meine mutter hat das internet
für sich entdeckt ich aber so schlimm
auf so eine schlimme art wenden wenn
meine mutter hatten ihm viel mit dem
internet und so zu tun die hat schon
früh weil die durch durch so unser haus
hatte mal um die falsche steine und
sodann hat angefangen im internet sich
schlau zu lesen und dann kamen sie das
erstmal mit dem internet rädchen
berührung weil sie da halt für den
rechtsstreit der dann damals war mit dem
haus hat sie ein paar banken lesen
jetzt hat sie aber das internet so
richtig für sich entdeckt weil sie nicht
versteht dass nicht alles was im
internet steht war ist leute jetzt kommt
eine true story und ich erzähle euch das
was ich vertraue und epub und ihr
hoffentlich nicht das nur weil ich ihre
gene habe dass irgendwas mit mir zu tun
hat ich war letztens zu hause für eine
woche deswegen wir auch so wenig videos
letzte woche gemacht
ja ich war zuhause für eine woche und
ich habe meine eltern besucht und meine
schwester und so und meine mutter hat
mir erzählt die erde ist gar keine runde
weil das ist auch nicht so wirklich eine
scheibe aber es ist wie ein ei das in
einer art badewanne liegt mit wasser
also sie liegt im wasser ja das hat sie
mir erzählt ich das ist nur sie hat es
im internet lesen und sie hat ganz viele
fakten darüber im internet gelesen also
ich glaube daran leute sie glaubt daran
keine ahnung warum mir das herz aber ja
meine mutter gehört jetzt zu diesem
armut menschen mein vater lacht er
darüber aber manchmal so der partie in
mundart immer gemacht und irgendwelche
komischen meine mama ist halt so ein
bisschen so eine crazy frau eine sehr
extrovertierte ich glaube dass den teil
habe ich von ihr so diese ist aber von
meinem vater habe ich dann zum glück
auch mal diese ruhige seite bekommen
diese ich denke zwei mal drüber nach
seite größer meine mama danke schön dass
du dich überhaupt geboren hast ne ich
war nämlich das vierte kind leute ich
bin das vierte kind von mir wo meine
eltern und das vierte kind war der
zuschuss fürs eigene heim
ja meine mama wollte ein eigenes haus
bauen und hat irgendwo gelesen dass man
beim vierten kind noch zuschuss kriegt
also danke deutschland dass ihr das
gemacht habt was sonst wäre ich jetzt
nicht hoffe welt und mein gott das ist
ein komischer gedanke nicht nicht
geboren worden zu sein
du kannst ja auch nicht vermissen knallt
gerade meinen kopf
das video wird viel zu lange also
tatsächlich waren geburtstagsfeiern bis
ins 19 jahrhundert hinein für
wohlhabende menschen in norddeutschland
ist es üblich männer mit 25 jahren
bekommen einen kranz mit alten socken
der hintergrund bedarf gedanke besteht
darin nun selbst eine alte socke zu sein
was kriegen fordert 25 frauen erhalten
im gegenzug einen einen schachtel kranz
alte schachtel oh mein gott ich krieg
dieses jahres bekannt macht mir bitte
jemand nehmen sie eine schachtel kranz
zum 30 butter ist es im norden
deutschland übrig die rathaus die
rathaustreppe oder den marktplatz zu
fegen
genau bis man von einer jungfrau frei
geküsst wird
frauen müssen aus dem brauch zu stehst
da und wächst und dann soll ich eine
frau küssen was ist wenn ich keine frau
küsst dann ist vorbei oder was in
england ist es gang und gäbe gäbe eine
kleine überraschung in einen kuchen zu
backen stimmt das habe ich schon mal
gelesen derjenige der das kleine
geschenk findet gilt als glückspilz in
den usa sowie italien gehört es zur
tradition nicht nur geschenke zu halten
sondern die gäste auch zu geschenken wow
in indien erscheinen derartigen
gastgeschenke im gegenzug als unhöflich
ok bist du der usa und italien
schenk auf deinem gast etwas in indien
es um spaß dafür in mexiko ist ein
kindergeburtstag ohne pinata nicht
vorstellbar
eine piñata ist ein mit süßigkeiten
vollgestopftes partner steht hier auf
dass kinder mit einem stockschlag von
diesem brauch wird erst abgelassen
sobald die stickereien herausfallen
diese tradition hat mittlerweile auch
us-amerikanische kinderzimmer reicht
klar es ist ein anlass zur freude da
habt ihr recht sächsische zeitung das
hat jeder jede kultur jedes land gleich
an seinem geburtstag freut man durch
manchmal wenn ich nach so was google und
dann verschiedene artikel lese lese ich
fast immer was die gleichen worte
wo ich mir denke machen wir das recht
nimmt dann die sächsische zeitung
einfach irgendein oder wenn ich nach
rezepten suche und dann sehe ich so
irgendwas zehn rezepte und eigentlich
sind alle fast gleich nicht weil das
unbedingt so genau gekocht werden muss
sondern weil die leute glaube ich
einfach auf der iaa zu einem rezept
gehen eine zutat zufrieden oder ein
bisschen was an einer zerrung bringen
und dann sagen hier schaut auf mein
rezept patches in japan ist es wichtig
dass das geburtstagsgeschenk nicht in
verbindung mit der zahl 4 steht denn es
gilt dass die zahl vier unglück bringt
es werden also beispielsweise kleine
brandin schachtel verschenkt in den vier
praline finden und es werden auch keine
gebinde aus vier blumen überreicht ja
gut wer sollte sie ihren blumenstrauß
mit vier blumen so wenig überhaupt in
blumen typisch für den geburtstag aber
auch hier gibt es einige sitten und
bräuche so werden beispielsweise in
vielen ländern keine lilienthaler oder
astern in den geburtstags raus
eingebunden denn diese blumen gelten als
toten blumen und sind trauerfloristik
vorbehalten in frankreich sind zudem
auch chöre sind themen lieber in trauer
grenzen gesehen hat den
geburtstagsgrüßen sind sich ein
blumenband alkohol gehören in vielen
ländern zu den typischen geschenken ja
anders hingegen ist es in der türkei
hier werden weder blumen noch alkohol
verstärkt sondern in erster linie
nützliche und praktische geschenke
übergeben hier eine gabel nutze sie
weise also eine gute seite www vorlagen
- geburtstagsgrüße punkt.de nun die
credits abzugeben geburtstagskarten
größe sind auch noch sehr beliebt und
wer nicht persönlich gratulieren kann
lässt den geburtstag sind seine glück
mit dem peppers zu kommen mittlerweile
aus dem bilderbuch es in der e-mail
einnahmen hingegen werden heute meist
persönlich ausgesprochen oder per
telefon übermittelt oder per facebook
oder xing gruppe wenn die einen
geburtstag feiert und es plant gründet
eine facebook gruppe ich hasse diese
whatsapp gruppen wo jeder seinen senf
dazugibt und du kannst es halt für
newton ich weiß aber macht facebook
gruppe danke ich finde aber schriftliche
einladung echt cool
große unterschiede hingegen gibt es in
zusammenhang mit gastgeschenken in den
usa- h das haben sie sich doch
wahrscheinlich wieder alle herauskopiert
geburtstags zeitung stimmt ich war
letztens auf einer hochzeit und da gab
es eine hochzeitszeitung und diesen
brauch kann ich gar nicht weil ich sonst
mal auftauchte nennt holen bin und das
deutsche tradition nicht kenne und
geburt hochzeit zeitung ist halt echt
ein ding und man kann auch eine
geburtstags zeitung machen jemanden
zusammen geburtstag wie eine zeitung du
machst halten zeitung und lässt es so
aussehen wie du eine bild zeitung oder
so und dann schreibst du so als ob die
ganze zeitung nur sich um diesen
personen dreht ja das ist gut so ich
habe ich gar nicht so wichtig so gezeigt
zu jeder gewerblichen torte gibt es
nämlich ein geschenk der männer blümchen
post machen den bindet sich einst
briefträger was ich schaffe nur die
hälfte kann ich das video bitte trotzdem
ganz sind orte nennen dankeschön gesagt
dann nicht klickt dann einfach sie hat
geburtstag aber zum geburtstag wünsche
ich mir dass ich krieg mit diesem video
machen da eine ganze benjamin blümchen
torte okay ich hoffe ich war ja noch
geburtstags erinnerungen also ganz kurz
meine geburtstags er in meinem schönsten
geburtstags erinnerungen und ich mich
erinnern kann dass wir sind auch
erinnerungen an meinem geburtstag
aber meine schwester war immer bisschen
schon mehr habe ich meine mama also
meine eltern sind auch cool so alles gut
aber meine machen meine schwester war
meine eltern immer meine eltern haben
sich immer nicht so viel mühe gegeben so
um so kleinigkeiten ich glaube es ist
aber auch ohne es zu beleidigen
ausländer eltern die die denkt nicht
daran dass du immer ein college block
haben musst oder den schönsten stift und
allerdings die sind um ihr praktischer
und meine schwester war wie ich die war
so auch schöne sachen machen und an
meinem siebten geburtstag hat sie mir an
meinem bett tost gebracht mit marmelade
und dann hat sie die heidelbeeren oder
so hat sich aus dieser mlada so
rausgepickt und damit nur sieben auch
den torf geschrieben
auch eine kerze reingesteckt das war
sehr schön das war eine tolle
geburtstags erinnerungen ansonsten hab
ich einmal ein geburtstag gefeiert
und ich darf da war ich 18 oder so wurde
ich acht oder neun also es war schon
etwas älter und ich war mir in meinem
zimmer gefeiert meine schwester hat
alles organisiert topfschlagen links
diese ganzen standard spiele und wir
wollen alles gegessen gefeiert und so
und irgendwann hatte ich ein
dieser moment oder ein oh mein gott mir
so schlecht habe ich ganz andere seite
bringen anhang ist so schlecht also ich
glaube ich habe wirklich zu viel
gegessen oder mir war das einfach zu
viel weil es waren wirklich viele kinder
diesem kleinen zimmer also ich fünfte
von ihnen möglich aber doch irgendwie so
um den dreh 15
ja und das war auch eine sehr komische
änderung wird weiß auch nicht warum das
weckt also nicht weggeht
diese erinnerung einmal habe ich an
meinem geburtstag
da war ich im freibad das war cool weil
eigentlich ist jetzt ja schon früher
woods irgendwie noch wärmer später im
september jetzt nicht mehr so und da
waren im freibad das war nicht richtig
schön und dann haben wir am horrorfilm
geguckt ich hatte da zwei mädchen
mitgenommen da war ich glaube ich wurde
ich 14 oder 13 oder so keine ahnung wie
halte ich da wurde noch eine schöne
angebote zur erinnerung
das nicht so wenige habe so richtig
coole sachen habe ich nicht zu meinem
geburtstag gemacht weil wir hatten nie
die kohle dafür also meine freundin die
die hat nur einen tag auf dem bauernhof
ein tag im fuchs spiel und sport scheune
in harburg danke fuchsie spiel und sport
channel für diese tollen erinnerung es
war immer sehr schön bei euch und
trampolinspringen so dass man tolle
geburtstage und schwimmen natürlich
mcdonald's ja dass meine schönsten
geburtstags erinnerung es komisch dass
mir diese eine kreis soest mit der
sieben darauf dass mir das so ins gehirn
eingebrannt ist weisheit wirklich noch
wieder aussieht und ich weiß noch wie
toll ich fand deswegen habe ich mir
wahrscheinlich gemerkt
happy birthday vanessa das traurig sowas
machen kannst ich habe beim video
gefallen ich hoffe ich höre euch ein
bisschen ablenken bisschen unter trainer
und ihr ja ich liebe meinen geburtstag
morgen kommt das letzte video zum thema
geburtstag also am 10 09
übrigens um einen pfarrer geburtstag am
10 meine oma hat am 8 9
das war immer so drei tage lang
geburtstage aber viele haben im
september geburtstag oder also das ist
so ein ding weil warte mal wann haben
eure eltern geklettert was man im
september geburtstag hat ja so november
dezember muss man gehört haben ne da es
ist kalt da kinder dann viele leute
kommen die ganzen babys im sommer und im
winter geburtstag hatten musste man zum
abruf gefühle geknetet haben ja bis dann
knattern